[Music]
let's take a look at Major League
Baseball's showcase at Google Cloud next
2023 where attendees could see in real
life just exactly how Google Cloud helps
the mle analyze Advanced metrics such as
bat speed and attack angle here with me
to share more is kartik Sanu from Google
Cloud Consulting Major League Baseball
uses statcast to aggregate millions of
data points to make sense of data and
you know make it available for their
customers to view interesting insights
and all of this is possible with Google
tech starting with and pause in all the
MLB ballparks that collect many millions
of metrics in real time process it on
Google cloud storage and bigquery to
then send it over to analytics
dashboards and interesting views that
the customers can then see in real time
so all of this is on Google check out
the short link above to learn more about
how the MLB uses Google Cloud
[Music]